hello everyone and welcome to the Grand
final of the Julius bar generation cup
as usual uh we have alireza and the
Magnus here and they also faced each
other in the final but in the final
magnets defeated alireza with a result
of three to zero and now alireza has a
chance at a do-over and we are going to
cover some games or maybe even just one
game all depends on how they've played
and want to spoil anything for you but
first game it was a really really crazy
one if you have time do check out all of
the games live uh not live I mean the
recordings of the live you will not be
sorry it was an extremely action-packed
and it's uh well I can show you the
moves but I cannot show you you know
their their facial expressions while
they were making those moves I can at
some points and I will try but not all
of them of course uh so I like I said in
the first game uh it was uh you know it
could have gone either way uh Alvarez
have tried something then Magnus tried
something then I always tried something
and in the end it could uh could be only
Magnus who could win but in the end it
really ended with a draw now Reza was up
the exchange Magnus was up to pawns so
yeah they've traded down and then they
then didn't draw a second game was a
fairly clean draw and third game ended
by Magnus winning that means that if Now
alireza does not win this game this is
the fourth game then uh it's all over
for him and if he can win this one then
it goes to Armageddon and he will get
another chance so let's check it out
alireza has the white pieces and he
opens with E4 we have Pawn to see five
Knight F3 we have quanta E6 and now Pawn
to B3 this is a very uh devastating
attack and um it's uh well it's really
is an attack because white just goes all
out here and it's a very rare move uh I
don't think anyone ever played it
against Magnus probably not in a serious
game so should be a lot of fun Magnus
plays Pawn to D5 and now Bishop to B5
with check Bishop D7 with captures
captures and now e captures on D5 we
have e captures and alireza just Castle
so what's the idea behind all of this
well the idea is to keep the a black
king in the center for as long as
possible we have Knight G2 F6 and now
comes Rook to E1 with check Bishop D7
and queen to E2 so now the question is
how is Magnus ever to Castle his King uh
the the king said or queen side while
the Bishop here will be hanging so of
course Magnus will try to find a way he
plays Rook to C8 now he wants to play
Rook to C6 followed by Rook to E6
challenge the White Queen and Castle the
safety and now it is a there are a
couple of nice moves that you could play
here but alireza plays the trickiest one
he plays Bishop to A3 the idea behind it
is that if Magnus continues with his
plan of Rook to C6 then nowadays I would
play Knight to D4 and here you just
don't have good moves The Rook is
attacked if you move the Rook let's say
Rook to A6 then comes a very unpleasant
Knight to F5 again with a triple attack
on the bishop here and if you don't move
the Rook let's say you capture the
Knight then the bishop is attacking the
bishop and then Bishop captures an E7
attacks the queen you move the queen and
then sorts of nasty discoveries are
possible we're gonna start with Bishop
captures on F6 with check and if Rook to
E6 you can even throw in this very nice
Bishop captures on G7 and if Rook
captures an E2 you're gonna play Rook
characters I need to King 38 and the
gobble up the rook and h8 and now you're
gonna have a two Rooks and a bishop for
a queen which is of course more than
enough even with Queen captures on C2
it's not really spectacular just Rook
back D1 and the game continues with
white being much much better
uh so after the special day to remove
magnets really spent his time here
wisely and he played Ponte A6 which is
the absolute top move recommended by the
engine and it is in fact now as of move
10 that we have a completely new game so
okay we have a pawn to C4 alireza wants
to open up the center and go further
after the black king Knight to fate now
and here comes Knight to E5 waiting for
this Knight to G6 to land uh because
then you can just trade and again black
will not be able to Castle uh so okay
Knight's the G6 but uh there's no reason
to trade right away the what you should
play here is Pawn to D4 it's actually a
winning move here uh Knight to G6 right
away is a game losing move but it's so
hard to realize why point is that after
Pawn to D4 uh what do you play here
again you can never Castle once you
Castle just Knight captures on G6 and
the bishop is lost so you're gonna have
to play something D captures on C4 now
again Knight captures in G6 and after
age captures you will play Bishop
captures and C5 will a triple attack
here and what what can you play if if
Rook the C7 to defend the bishop then
Bishop B6 cures The Rook here and of
course if you try Knight to G8 then the
King again cannot Castle you will still
be uh forced to move the Knight and then
Castle probably if you're lucky you'll
be able to play King to a fate and then
maybe develop but still white should be
a lot better uh if you if you ask the
engine of course the engine says white
is completely winning but okay not an
easy idea at the spot though it has to
play the Knight to C3 and now Pawn to D
for Magnus says in the sense is there's
something there and he does not allow
Pawn to D4 Knight to A4 now going after
the C5 pawn and now King to f8 finally
Magnus on pins here and he's now ready
to activate his pieces we have Queen to
F3 uh Bishop to D6 now puts pressure on
the Knight we have Knight back to D3 and
now Pawn to B6 not allowing Queen
captures and B7 uh Pawn to B4 biology he
also would very much like to open up
this diagonal C captures on B4 we have
Knight captures on B4 and now Bishop
captures on B4 even with Bishop captures
with check and King to G8 Magnus slowly
but Charlie is castling his King
artificially maybe some H5 H4 action and
then the Rook comes into the game this
way so Queen sorry Queen to B7
uh goes after the A6 spawn and the
Magnus even uh you know welcomes it with
Queen captures and A6 and now Pawn to H5
now uh he gives up a little bit of
material but he survives the attack with
knights the B2 uh Pawn to H4 and pawn to
H3 stopping further advancement of the
pawn Knight to F4 now we have Queen to
B5 and uh Rook to H5 coming into the
game with Tempo on the queen on B5 Rook
to uh sorry Rook to E5 and now Queen to
C7 uh we have Rook captures on H5 Knight
six characters on H5 and now Rook to E1
now it is it brings The Rook into the
game and now just Queen back the B7
threatening Checkmate uh we have Queen
to G5 stopping Checkmate and now Queen
to C6 uh we have Pawn to D3 and now Rook
the E8 offering a rook trade and the
alireza goes for it with Rook captures
Queen characters and now Bishop to D2
you have to activate the bishop somehow
and here you are threatening to win a
piece and uh Magnus what he should play
is Knight to E2 with check and after
King to F1 now you play Pawn to F5 and
there's really no good way to continue
this probably something like C5 but the
problem is if the pawn is captured of
course then a nice nice the G3 check
with uh you sacrifice one Knight but
then the other Knight picks up the queen
so instead after Bishop to D2 Queen to
E2 was played by Magnus his idea is okay
you capture everything on F4 I'm just
gonna capture on B2 and I should have a
a better game but alireza says Nope
you've actually blundered a pawn there
and he goes for Bishop captures on F4
Magnus captures back but not not now not
a queen captures on F4 first queen to d8
with check forcing the king to the H
file and then of course the H4 Pawn
comes uh comes off with Tempo so King H7
we have Queen captures an H4 with the
check King to G8 and now Queen captures
an F4 now Magnus does win back the ninth
but now King to H2 and if you count the
material alireza is up to Pawns
so we have Pawn to G6 and now uh Queen
to B8 with check and this is a problem
now because the Queens are on the same
file and now C5 is also an idea for
alireza I think the H7 now comes Pawn to
C5 and now magnets of course cannot
capture he would lose the queen here so
Pawn to B5 uh and now Pawn to C6 with
Queen captures and F2 uh Queen to D6 Now
with uh Queen back to C2 putting the
queen behind the pass pawn and pawn to
C7 Queen back to C1 and now Pawn to A3
uh we have Queen uh sorry Pawn to G5 and
now Queen to E5 we are King to G6 and
now Queen to E4 with check King to H6
now comes Queen to E5 and King to G6 we
have Queen to D6 with check here uh H4
interestingly is the only winning move
but um you know yeah they're both
playing an increment pretty much so
Queen to D6 with check Pawn to F6 Now by
Magnus and now Queen to G3 and now it's
not that clear how to how to win this
game we have King to F7 on the H4 G
captures an H4 and queen back to D6
battle it is a king to G6 and now King
to H3 we have Queen to H1 with check now
the uh magnus's Queen can just continue
checking that white king uh first queen
to H2 and now Queen back to C1 not
allowing the queening of the pawn queen
back to D6 and now Queen to H1 with
check and now if alireza wants to
continue the game he has to start
marching forward with his King so King
G4 Queen captures and G2 King captures
on H4 Queen H1 check and King to G4 we
have Queen to D1 with check King to F4
and now Queen to E2 this is a very nasty
trick because uh Magnus is waiting for
alireza to bring a Queen into the game
and then he will just play Queen to H2
check and skewer uh the uh the the king
and queen here on this diagonal but the
problem is alireza does not promote the
pawn to a queen alireza actually
promotes it to an it under promotes it
and this is the phase that Magnus made
at the one from the thumbnail if you
guys are interested uh so here we have
Queen do F2 we check now it doesn't work
because Queen H2 check you capture okay
just Knight captures up a full piece so
Queen to F2 would check with King the E4
and now again uh Magnus can still uh
sort of get back into the game he has to
play Queen to F5 check and pick up the
Knight but he played Queen to E2 with
check King characters and D4 Queen the
B2 check and King to D5 with seconds on
the clock it's not easy to you know find
stuff uh Queen to G2 with check now
comes King to E6 Queen to H3 check King
to E7 and now Queen captures and C8 so
he does win the Knight but um you know
it's it's not gonna work as he will lose
further material so Queen captures an F6
check King to H5 now comes Queen to E5
with check King to G4 and now Queen
captures on B5 here uh alireza misses uh
an instant win with Queen to E6 check
because of course you force a queen
trade and there's no way uh magnets can
stop this Pawn but you know seconds on
the clock Queen captures on B5 was
played and now he will still have to
work for his meal we have Queen date
shade now comes uh Queen to D5 we have
King to F4 uh uh Queen to E4 with check
King to G3 Now Pawn to D4 the pawn
starts marching forward Queen G7
checking to D6 Queen to f8 to check
Queen to E7 blocking and now Queen to B8
with the check so now you merely have to
block checks with the queen and the pawn
and use that to advance your pawns up
the board so King E6 Queen to see it
with check King E5 Queen to h a checking
F6 Queen to eight with check King to F5
so the only thing Magnus can hope for
here is for alvareza to go for a mouse
slip or for a disconnect or uh you know
maybe maybe uh he will get a draw or you
know using the 50 move rule if alireza
does not capture anything uh or or make
a pawn move but it's very unlikely as
every few moves it will be a pawn move
so Quincy checking G5 Queen to G8
checking h8 Queen to eight Queen to D6
again with checking F3 Queen F6 checking
E4 Queen to E5 check King to D3 and now
your queen is nicely centralized you are
ready to execute file of course you can
never touch the pawn if Queen capture
spawn then you can just deliver a nice
check and pick up that Queen so King C4
with D6 Queen captures and A3 but now
King to G7 now the pawn is too far
Advanced Queen to H3 King to F7 and now
Queen to D7 with check King F6 with
Queen to DHR King E7 Queen E7 Queen to
h8 with check King to F7 Queen to H5
with check King to G7 Queen to G4 with
check King to f8 Queen to see it with
check Queen E8 Queen to C5 and now Queen
to E6 so you still have to do a little
bit of good work to get at that point
actually of the board King C3 and now
Queen to E7 we have Queen to B2 Queen to
E4 and now King day one so Magnus gets
his King all the way to the corner to
try and make sure that all it is uh
can't trade off uh Queens easily so King
E6 Queen to B6 King to C4 and now Queen
E3 checking the five Queen F3 check King
65 Queen to A3 we have King to C6 uh
Queen to A8 with checking 37 and queen
to H1 so now is magnus's best chance uh
to you know invoke the 50 move rule if
he can stop that pawn from uh making a
move in in the next 50 moves 24 checking
a two queen to D2 check King A1 Queen A5
check King to B2 and a lot of checks
were given here uh there okay there we
had a pawn move uh so now it's merely a
you know a question of uh how to do it
uh here of course a few more checks uh
now you you paralyzed the pawn by
pulling the queen on the same file as
the king a few more checks few more
checks and now I checked to the blanking
King C1 Queen to C6 Chair King 31 Queen
A4 checking into Queen G4 checking F1
Queen to F5 checking G1 King G7 Queen to
D4 with check King to F7 of course the
pawn is always nicely protected Queen to
C4 checking a queen E6 queen of Fortune
Queen F6 Queen is C4 check King the f8
and now Queen to be for checking to G7
Queen to B7 and now a queen to D4 with
check finally uh controlling the d8
square as well King H1 King H6 unpinning
with Queen to C6 check King to G5 Queen
B5 checking to H4 Queen to F5 uh and now
d8 queen and the reason uh Magnus tried
it this way is because now he played
Queen to F2 check and he was hoping for
alireza to grab that Queen because if he
does then it's still made the black king
has nowhere to go as you can see but of
course alireza did not play that all it
is after this queen to have to check
just play King to G5 and he was in this
position and move 130 that Magnus
Carlsen resigned in the game and this is
uh the first uh game that alireza wins
against Magnus in this match so uh first
three games in the previous match Magnus
won then two draws then Magnus wins and
this is basically the seventh game it
took alireza seven games to grab a full
point which means that he equalizes the
match and now he forces Armageddon and
let's see what happened in Armageddon so
this is the Armageddon game alireza got
the white pieces which means that Magnus
is the one who won in the bidding war as
he got the black pieces in Armageddon
it's always better to have black Magnus
uh bid 8 minutes and 56 seconds until it
is a bit nine minutes and 10 seconds so
it was fairly close 16 seconds
difference uh but um somehow Magnus
always knows uh how much his opponents
will uh you know bet but I don't think
it's that I think Magnus says what's the
lowest I'm comfortable playing with
against alireza it's 856 any palades
that chooses lower then I just don't
believe that he's comfortable playing
with that little time against me so it
might also be the reason why Magnus
always wins the bidding war for for the
Soki Magnus will start with uh uh eight
minutes and 56 seconds and alireza of
course with the full 15. so let's check
it out and of course alireza has to win
if it's a drawing on again then the game
the the match ends in uh magnus's favor
I'm just gonna switch this a little a
little on the robot to an A so it
doesn't confuses you guys uh let me just
switch that real quickly there we go uh
so let's check it out well it is that
with the white pieces opens with E4 and
get this C5 Knight to F3 E6 and again B3
Magnus was really weirded out uh might
even been a little bit disgusted when he
saw this because he's like okay you're
not uh trying this again obviously I
checked uh I checked uh what you played
with the engine after the previous game
and he plays A6 right away instead of
the D5 that he played in the A6 indeed
is the top move recommended by the
engine so G3 we have Pawn to D5 and now
e captures on D5 we have e captors and
now there is a game where Queen E2 and
D4 were played but Bishop to G2 is what
alireza plays and it is now already as
of move 6 that we have a completely new
game okay Knight F6 by Magnus with
castles and Bishop to E7 so a lot
different than the game that we've just
shown as now Magnus is castling to
safety very early on so D4 castles
Knight to C3 now the C6 and not Knight
the A4 again allereza puts his Knight on
the on the rim of the board see capture
Sunday for Knight captures and Bishop to
G4 going after alireza's Queen Knight
back to E2 and now Rook to E8 alireza
has to make sure that none of the pieces
get traded off for nothing you know
carelessly as that will uh severely
diminish his chances of winning the game
so F3 Bishop to D7 and now Bishop to E3
we have Pawn to B5 by Magnus Knight back
to C3 and now Rook the C8 mobilizing all
of his pieces you can see how they are
very nicely uh in this formation uh
Bishop to F2 and now Bishop to A3 we
have Rook to B1 uh and of course he
wants to stop Bishop to B2 to go after
the rookie Knight and try and trade
further pieces uh Knight to B4 now the
Knight is paralyzed as the C2 Pawn will
be under attack we have Rook to E1 and
now alireza plays Ponder uh sorry Magnus
play spawn to H5 it was uh uh here
magnets actually could have one with
Pawn to D4 but it's the the problem with
uh Armageddon probably he's not looking
for ways to win uh point is that you you
can't really do anything about this you
cannot play Knight capture because your
knight would hang here and if you move
this Knight then Magnus will just trade
and play Knight captures and C2 and this
is just game over you create a fast Pawn
you you snatch the C2 Pawn uh there's no
way to defend this so instead he played
Pawn to H5 which also makes sense you
wanna start attacking here maybe even
Advance all the way to H3 Queen D2 and
not Knight captures on C2 a temporary uh
peace sacrifice because after Queen
captures and C2 comes spawn to B4 of
course we have Queen D3 and now B
captures in C3 Knight captures and now
Rook characters anyone with check with
Rook captures and Bishop to B4 now uh
probably just preparing further trades
uh Bishop to D4 and now Queen to A5 we
have Rook the 3 and not just Bishop
characters and C3 Magnus is only uh well
idea here is that he does not want to
lose this game Bishop captures and queen
captures on A2 Pawn to H3 Queen captures
on B3 now he also creates a past a pawn
onto G4 with Queen to C for offering a
trade and now Queen to D2 We have Pawn
to D4 attacking the bishop and the rook
and now Bishop captures on D4 Queen to
C1 check Magnus gives back one Pawn to
force a queen trade Queen captures on C1
with Rook captures and C1 with check
King H2 and now Rook the C2 uh of course
now he would very much like to see this
bishop somewhere let's say here and then
capture the light Square Bishop Rook to
E7
I put pressure on the bishop now comes
Bishop to B5 with an idea of Bishop to
F1 so alireza brings The Rook back but
not Knights the D5 with Bishop to E5 and
now Pawn to F6 attacks the bishop Bishop
to D6 and not even Knights to E3 uh
threatening to capture the bishop and
forcing a trade here Rook captures an E3
and of course now you gain access to the
back rank Bishop to F1 King to G3 Rook
captures on G2 with check King to F4 and
now Rook to uh Rook back to D2 goes
after the bishop Bishop to C5 and now
Rook to D5 again harasses the bishop
Rook to E8 with check with King to H7
and Bishop to fade uh sorry Bishop to f8
now hoping to get that Rook into the
attack but now Pawn to G5 with check
King G3 and now Rook the D2 Magnus is
now threatening Pawn to H for checkmate
so the only move for alireza is Pawn to
F4 which he plays H for check with King
F3 uh Bishop captures an H3 we have
better of the E7 trying to go after the
base of the pawn chain Bishop to G2 with
check with King to E3 and now Rook to D1
and now you have to play uh King to E2
this is the way to play this but in the
game uh sorry King uh King T2 is the way
to play but King the F2 was played by
alireza and now Magnus is again winning
on the H3 and now we have Bishop
captures and F6 but also G captures an
F4 we have Bishop to E5 and now uh Rook
the D2 check uh probably because Magnus
is still just trying not to lose this if
he wanted to win a rook to F1 check is
the way to go because after King E2
there's F3 check and after the king
moves Rook to F2 checking to D1 and now
Rook D2 and there is no stopping
promotion you can even play F2 give up
the rook and then bring your queen into
the game doesn't really matter
uh so after Bishop B5 uh Rook the D2
check with King to E1 and now Pawn to F3
very similar now trying to give up The
Rook this way and alireza goes for it as
there really is nothing better Rook this
Rook D7 tracking to Jade and now King
chapter Sandy too uh Pawn to F2 and now
it seems like there's no way to stop
magnets from queening but there might be
a way to actually save the game there is
only one game that saves the game uh for
alireza uh feel free to pause the video
and try to find this only move that
draws the game doesn't win it so just
don't lose the game there's only one
move while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations I'm really solving
a tricky puzzle and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's Rook to
G7 with check of course the king cannot
go to h8 under the mask of the bishop
then you're just lost so you have to go
to f8 and now Rook to G5 that's how you
solve this and now if F1 Queen which is
the strongest move now Rook the F5 check
forces a trade Rook a queen capture
spawn captures and okay you're down a
pawn but you control the dark squares
and it's uh any game of Bishops of
opposite color so it will be a draw
however after F2 alireza played Pawn to
G5 and this simply will not to do pawn
to F1 Queen Pawn to G6 and now Queen to
F2 with check King to D3 here we have
Queen to F5 with check and it was in
this position and move 56 that alireza
feature resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here not only
that he's not winning but he's also
losing the game as after the king moves
you can simply play Queen cut after sun
G6 and now you simply don't have enough
even uh winning the black queen is silly
because you will just be down two uh two
pawns and the piece so without that
there's really nothing to to try even uh
so yeah after Queen to F5 check
algerizer resigns and the Magnus Carlsen
is the winner of Julius bar generation
cup I believe second win in a row so
that is a very good stuff and in an
interview after the match Magnus said
that he's not very happy with his play
but he's also not very happy with
alireza's play basically he said that no
one played well other than Dennis
lazovic lazovic he said it last week
played incredible but other than that
that he is not satisfied uh so yeah uh
those were the games hope you guys
enjoyed it uh uh uh I hope you who you
were able to solve this one it was not
an easy position to stall after this F2
move but you know sometimes you have to
look for you know a nice check and then
prepare another check you have to
combine two tactics uh you know in order
to solve it but yeah uh sorry for a bit
of a longer video but I thought you guys
should see both of them if you have time
uh you know maybe maybe an hour and a
half two hours to do check out the
entire match it's very very enjoyable uh
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank girls
and justfestival.org.gg Phil Malthus
Jaren Asher rohantana and David Kimura
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day